Leave the World Behind is an endof the
world drama Thriller that asks the
question just how bad can Julia Roberts
dance from the creator of Mr Robot and
based on the novel of the same name this
movie has everything from tanker crashes
teeth falling out and the latest Taylor
Swift album so in this video I want to
take a deep dive into some of the
biggest mysteries to get to the bottom
of what's going on now make sure to like
And subscribe as we delve into this
post-apocalyptic Adventure but uh don't
bring your
[Music]
Tesla
meet these sanfords just your typical
New York family I fuing hate people
that's Amanda and as we'll come to see
she's got her own narrow-minded view of
humanity she and her family are on an
impromptu vacation to Leave the World
Behind which is not only the name of the
movie but the first line of this
gorgeous rental property they'll be
spending their time at it's quite apt
that the first shot is of the sun rising
over Earth and as the film progresses
we'll see we get further and further
away from it just as our characters move
further and further from the world they
once knew the blue color of our world is
mimicked by the world of the sanfords
they drive a blue car wear blue clothing
and blue lighting often bathes our
characters as they confront the perils
around them blue here represents
security it's the world we know but as
the film progresses this will slowly
erode as the world descends into chaos
even the local market Point Comfort with
the blue signage gives off these safe
Vibes the film is split into five parts
each with its own focal point part one
is the house and the Sanford settle into
what's supposed to be a fun vacation but
things get off to a strange start as
their day at the beach is ruined when a
giant oil tanker crashes into the shore
I just hate when that happens this is
but the first of a series of strange
occurrences that befall our family
ironically enough the name of this
tanker is the White Lion a white lion is
said to be a symbol for the well-being
of Mother Earth so it crashing into the
shore is some ominous foreshadowing if
you listen closely you can make out a
police officer stating that there have
been several of these beachings up the
coast and it has something to do with
their navigation systems when our family
gets back to the rental both the Wi-Fi
and TVs aren't working so basically a
vacation from Hell clay Sanford the
father an English and media college
professor tells his wife he's been asked
to write the Ford to a book of one of
his students writing about how media
serves as both an escape and a
reflection it's a quick line but it also
points to what this movie is both an
escape from reality but a reflection of
the world we live in but the film really
starts with the introduction of George
and Ruth Scott they are the owners of
this rental and because there's a black
out in the state and the roads are
clogged they've decided to spend the
night something Amanda Sanford isn't too
happy about I'm sorry I just uh I don't
feel comfortable staying in a house
with black people Amanda tries to hide
her Prejudice not believing a person of
of color could own a house this
expensive this is this is your house she
even believes George and Ruth must be
the help and are trying to con them
maybe he's the handyman she's the
housekeeper and when offered a drink by
George she turns him down I'll pass the
director shows this ju position by
Framing Amanda and Clay on the left
white and light and George and Ruth on
the right black and Knight we'll see
similar justos throughout the film such
as this shot between Amanda and George
in front of this black and white
abstract painting George's Blackness is
something he hides from his
predominantly white renters Amanda notes
that there are no family photos around
the house instead any information that
would point to the owners being black
are locked away in his office which we
only see briefly just a few miles away
from George's home we'll see clay drive
past Tanny Farms named after Roger B
Tanny the United States fifth Chief
Justice of the United States who
infamously ruled that African-Americans
could not be considered us citizens nor
could the government prohibit slavery
that's not to say Ruth and George aren't
without their Prejudice either Ruth goes
on to say if the World falls apart trust
should not be dled out easily to anyone
especially white people the night gets
even stranger when a National Emergency
Broadcast appears on screen this is
followed by a brief CNN Chiron stating
that a Cyber attack has brought power
outages all along the east coast totally
random but bonus points if you cut the
beach towel novel on Amanda's B side
table Sam Ismail the director had a
character named Irving write a novel of
the same name in his show Mr Robot now
part two is titled the curve and is a
reference to George's job part of his
work in Investments involves studying
graphs their ups and downs and their
curves he says that if you analyze this
stuff for long enough you start to see
patterns and he noticed something
strange in the days leading up to these
events furthermore he had an extremely
wealthy defense contractor move vast
sums of money out of his accounts a few
days prior almost as if he knew
something was going to happen George
will head over to his neighbor's house
the Huxley this is no doubt a nod to
English writer and philosopher Aldis
Huxley who often explored themes such as
the dangers of technology in his work
when George finds the huxley's place
trashed he Ventures to the nearby Beach
and finds a plane crash only for moments
later to witness another plane crash in
almost The Identical spot so it seems
someone or something is programming
these planes to land in a certain area
just like the oil tankers washed all
along the coast later in the film we'll
see a fleet of unknown Teslas autopilot
their way to the freeway where they
crash into one another making it
impossible to leave the city is this all
a freak accident or is something more
coordinated at play throughout the film
we'll see various animals responding to
the events around them a herd of deer
hundreds in size appear in front of rows
Birds swarm in circles and even a group
of flamingos Land by their pool we hear
a brief r radio announcement that some
sort of catastrophic environmental
disaster has happened and it's impacted
migration pattern so that may have
something to do with it part three is
titled the noise a reference to this
earpiercing Screech that is so powerful
it even breaks the glass on the house
its Origins remain a mystery but
survivalist Dany thinks he has the
answer later in the movie when Amanda
and clayon Archie gets sick and starts
losing his teeth George remembers that
his contractor friend Dany was a
survivalist and may have some medication
Danny states that this noise was likely
a microwave attack similar to what
happened to us diplomats in Cuba in 2016
it's possible that an enemy has
harnessed this power and used it against
the American people Archie was also
bitten by an insect so never quite sure
if his teeth falling out was the result
of the noise or this bite when clay goes
rushing into town hoping to find any
information he can on what's going on he
encounters a drone dropping off hundreds
of these red flyers in what appears to
be the Arabic I had it translated and it
roughly States quote we ask you pay
immediate attention to what we say in
this publication we have the most
dangerous and destructive explosives in
history and we leave this horrific fact
for you to contemplate and stress the
validity of what is said I'm using this
on your land and steps must be taken to
stop the resistance built for peaceful
surrender of your land Danny says his
friend in San Francisco experiened the
same thing but the Flyers there were in
Korean or Mandarin but if you're
invading an English speaking country why
rain down Flyers that no one can even
read this leads into George's theory of
what's going on when he was talking to
his defense contractor friend he said
there was one three-step maneuver to
overthrow a government that scared him
more than anything this starts with
stage one isolation the disabling of
communication and transportation this is
why we see the satellites not working no
GPS and various forms of transportation
like these electric Teslas used to block
off meain arteries into and out of
cities stage two is synchronized chaos
you want to throw as much misinformation
as possible like those flyers to scare
and divide the people eventually leading
to step three an eventual coup whether
this happens by Civil War or other means
it results in the collapse of the
government you can actually overthrow a
government without having to send in
troops it'll overthrow itself so if a
group of countries got together and
enacted this three-step plan and were
successful they could potentially topple
the United States at the end of the film
we'll see New York hit with nuclear
bombs it's not certain whether these are
American bombs let loose on their own
people or if they're from another
country the film also paints a jaded
view on Humanity so much so that it begs
the question whether we deserve what we
got not only are we destroying the
planet check out the conscious decision
to litter the beach in trash but Amanda
refers to herself and Humanity as
terrible people I hate being terrible
like this clay leaves a poor
Spanish-speaking woman in need and and
Archie takes creepy photos of Ruth it's
only Rosie who's still young enough to
hold on to that innocence perhaps that's
why she's so obsessed with friends it's
a fantasy world where everything is
light and fun which is why Ruth says
this about the show but it's almost
nostalgic for a time that never existed
friends is a show that helps us ignore
how awful Humanity really is as Amanda
goes on to State I think we know we're
living aive and agreed upon mass
delusion to help us ignore and keep
ignoring how awful we really are rose
will later explain why she needs to find
out the ending to friends because of her
love for the
characters I care about them to which
your brother remarks maybe you shouldn't
this back and forth is especially
important considering how the movie ends
Rose stumbles upon the thorn household
the Family Danny told us built a secret
underground bunker in the event of a
catastrophe I found it quite interesting
that the shelter is called Commodus
after a Roman Emperor who was
assassinated and it's quite odd that the
family that's supposed to be here is
nowhere to be found as the shelter boots
up we get confirmation that the White
House and several major cities are under
attack by Rogue Armed Forces but we
never find out specifically who it's
even possible that these forces come
from within the US itself there are also
increased levels of radiation detected
so we can assume these are atomic bombs
of some kind you'll see that Rose is
bathed in the safe blue light of the
shelter while upstairs the real world is
painted crimson red danger there's also
something to be said about the items
stocked away in the pantry with minor
exceptions almost every product here has
had some sort of push back with being
racially or culturally insensitive from
Aunt jamaa Uncle Ben and Crea wheat's
portrayal of African-American
stereotypes to Indian Head cornmeal
beside it Indian orange drink mix and I
guess they didn't like the Chinese
cherry flavor and on the bottom left
burilla pasta whose president has a
history of stating homophobic beliefs on
the top right we'll see Dixie beer which
has recently changed the name of its
brand as to not be associated with the
slave owning Confederacy and last but
not least Trader Joe's mix can beer that
they titled Trader Jose's if food isn't
your thing how about the vast collection
of DVDs and as luck would have it they
have the final episode of Friends Rose
has been so desperate to watch the title
of the finale is the last one which is
also the title of the final chapter of
this film as Rose clicks play the film
abruptly ends we don't get to find out
anything that happened to our character
but maybe that's the point should we
even care maybe you shouldn't especially
if these are all terrible people our
characters have left their world behind
and so too must we leave them we are
briefly put in their position unsure of
what will happen next many of the
questions this movie asks have no
answers and it's up to us to decide who
invaded will Ross end up with Rachel and
what will happen next let me know what
you think in the comments below thanks
for watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much